gesundheitsminister sparen legt sich
fest rückkehrer aus corona
risikogebieten müssen sich künftig auf
das virus testen lassen
hiobsbotschaft für spanien
die zahl der neuinfektionen steigt
wieder rasant die tourismusbranche
fürchtet einen kollaps alarm im
deutschen wald borkenkäfer und
trockenheit sorgen in vielen regionen
für einen kahlschlag
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am montag die vom
sport hat norbert lehmann dabei ein
stück von mir heute vor einem halben
jahr ist der erste mensch in deutschland
positiv auf das corona virus getestet
worden
seitdem hat sich unser leben gravierend
verändert denn das virus hat sich immer
weiter ausgebreitet
auch durch unsere mobilität
gesundheitsminister spahn hat jetzt
entschieden wer aus einem risikogebiet
zurückkehrt muss sich bei einreise auf
corinna testen lassen
weltweit gelten derzeit nur die meisten
eu-länder nicht als risikogebiet wer
aber beispielsweise aus luxemburg
einigen balkanländern der türkei oder
ägypten wieder nach deutschland
zurückkehrt fällt nun unter die neue
regelung
thomas münten zudem corona test stellen
die am düsseldorfer flughafen
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten wie der
türkei oder tansania heute mittag
ich habe den test auch in der türkei
machen lassen am wochenende war es ein
bisschen schwierig weil das am
wochenende nicht machen
und deswegen war dazu zwölf schon
abgelaufen ist muss ich noch mal machen
das geht ja darum dass man guckt das
jetzt dass man das überprüft ob jemand
den virus mitbringt oder nicht und wie
gesagt ich hätte auch dafür bezahlt das
ist kostenlos 1700 tests gab es bislang
zwölf positive proben am abend reagierte
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen auf
die steigenden infektionszahlen wir
sehen das mit zunehmende reisetätigkeit
auch das infektionsrisiko hier in
deutschland wieder steigt gerade auch
aus risikogebieten wie der türkei oder
dem westbalkan und zum schutz der
einreisenden aber vor allem auch alle
bürgerinnen und bürger sollten wir dann
eben auch eine testung vornehmen also
eine testpflicht was die kosten angeht
sieht sein nrw kollege die touristen in
der pflicht wenn das testen
verpflichtend ist dann finde ich dürfen
die kosten auch nicht bei der
solidargemeinschaft liegen sondern da
muss ein vernünftiger pragmatischer weg
gefunden werden diese kosten dann auch
von denjenigen die gemeint haben dass
sie in einem risikogebiet oder machen
müssen
letzten endes selber
werden bayern möchte künftig auch an
großen bahnhöfen und grenzübergängen
testen
denn oftmals werden gerade im urlaub
nicht nur in den risikogebieten abstand
und sicherheitsregeln nicht eingehalten
es geht auch um das verbreitungsgebiet
des virus und deshalb richtet sich ein
solches verhalten gegen das gemeinwohl
die kosten je test werden in düsseldorf
auf rund 70 euro geschätzt die jeder
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten selbst zu
tragen hätte bisher konnten sich die
gesundheitsminister der länder ja nicht
auf eine testpflicht einigen theo wieso
jetzt plötzlich doch dieser beschluss
aus berlin nur ich glaube da hat heute
bei einigen der politische wecker
geklingelt endlich muss man sagen denn
die sommerferien enden ja nicht so ganz
überraschend den anfang macht schon am
wochen in den mecklenburg vorpommern und
seit längerem ist klar dass die
bisherige vorschrift für reisende aus
risikogebieten sich bei den
gesundheitsämtern zu melden und dann in
quarantäne zu gehen nur von einem
kleineren teil eingehalten wird
die gesundheitsminister waren bisher vor
einer test flicht zurückgeschreckt unter
anderem aus praktikabilität und aus
kostengründen warum soll die
allgemeinheit wie habe es gerade gehört
für das bewusst eingegangene risiko von
reisendenzahlen das stimmt alles aber am
ende steigen dann doch die
infektionszahlen jetzt also nutzt der
gesundheitsminister sein
infektionsschutzgesetz um die tests
verpflichtend zu machen eine
entsprechende verordnung soll kommende
woche in kraft treten genau ein halbes
jahr nach dem ersten deutschen kroner
fall scheint die vorausschauende
vorbeugung der politik durchaus noch
steigerungsfähig interessante
hintergründe vielen dank der für theo
schauen wir uns die immer weiter
ansteigende zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland an
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 560 menschen
angesteckt corona kommen schleichend
zurück aber mit aller macht warnt
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
nicht nur mit blick auf die urlauber
sondern auch auf den corona ausbruch im
eigenen bundesland betroffen ist die
gemeinde mamming in niederbayern hier
war gestern bekannt geworden dass sich
mehr als 170 erntehelfer
infiziert haben fast 500 menschen stehen
unter quarantäne und die sorge ist groß
dass sich das virus auch außerhalb des
gurken hofs ausbreitet irgendwann jetzt
wird ein großes zelt aufgebaut so stark
ist der andrang
alle warten auf einen corner test der
virus ausbruch auf dem gemüsehof
beunruhigt die menschen in mamming und
die arbeitgeber in der ganzen region die
furcht ist groß selbst in quarantäne
geschickt zu werden oder den betrieb
schließen zu müssen
das sind wir denn die arbeit können bei
der chef gesagt wir sollen uns bitte
testen lassen nicht dass die ganze firma
und anschließend muss er es von der
arbeit heim geschickt worden dh der
brauch der negatives ergebnis damit er
mehr dahin werk ausgangspunkt ein großer
gemüsehof wo arbeiter aus osteuropa die
saison über in containern leben
bayern will die kontrollen verschärfen
häufiger prüfen unangemeldet und auch
nachts für den hof gab es hygieneregeln
gegen die wohl verstoßen wurde so der
vorwurf
die staatsregierung wird deshalb die
bußgelder deutlich erhöhten
der bußgeldrahmen wird erhöht von 5.000
für 58 auf 25.000 das heißt beim verstoß
eines betriebes und der nichteinhaltung
des chemie konzept eine fünffach höhere
strafe die dann angewendet wird 25.000
euro für manchen kleinbetrieb in dieser
situation kaum noch zu tragen
drastische maßnahmen auch für den
gemüsehof wachleute kontrollieren das
gelände wurde eingezäunt
fast 500 menschen arbeiter und
familienangehörige dürfen das gelände
vorläufig nicht mehr verlassen
ins ausland da vermeldet das urlaubsland
spanien wieder deutlich steigende
infektionszahlen am stärksten betroffen
sind die regionen navarra aragon und
katalonien mit der touristen metropole
barcelona die katalanischen behörden
haben bereits konsequenzen gezogen neue
ausgangssperren und eine strenge masten
pflicht die tourismusbranche fürchtet
den kollaps hatten die spanier doch
trotz corona auf viele urlauber aus dem
ausland gehofft crystal hat fieber
messen ist pflicht vor dem restaurant
oder barbesuch und ab mitternacht
herrscht sperrstunde katalonien
verschärft die korona maßnahmen und die
kontrollen masken verweigerer werden
freundlich in die schranken verwiesen
denn die infektionen steigen aber die
vorsicht sinkt bei touristen und
einheimischen der regionalpräsident wird
deutlich ein saufgelage ist keine party
das ist ein akt der rücksichtslosigkeit
denken sie daran dass die meisten
neuinfizierten junge leute sind wie sie
spaniens image als sicheres urlaubsland
bröckelt mit folgen gäste aus
großbritannien müssen jetzt nach ihrer
rückkehr in quarantäne
das hatte die britische regierung quasi
über nacht entschieden die
schutzmaßnahmen sind besser als in
london
es ist ziemlich verrückt dafür jetzt
eine quarantäne zu verhängen
es hat mich überrascht weil ich es nur
einen tag vor meiner abreise erfahren
habe aber es ist richtig
immer mehr neue fälle spanien gelingt es
nicht die infektionsketten ausreichend
nachzuverfolgen
es fehlt schlicht an personal die
außenministerin betont aber spanien sei
sicher wie in jedem anderen eu-staat
haben wie infektions cluster aber die
sind in spanien alle unter kontrolle
ein urlaubsland kämpft um seine urlauber
und damit auch um das wirtschaftliche
überleben auch in einem urlaubsort in
oberösterreich ist die zahl der
bestätigten corona infektion wieder
gestiegen in sankt wolfgang am
wolfgangsee sind es nun insgesamt 53
fälle fast alle betroffenen sind
mitarbeiter der dortigen
tourismusbetriebe das ergebnis hunderter
weiterer test steht noch aus junge
saison mitarbeiter in der gastronomie
sollen ausgiebig gemeinsam gefeiert
haben corona schränkt die wahl des
urlaubsziels ein welche auflagen in den
ländern europas gelten das gibt's zum
nachlesen in unserer zdf heute app im
zusammenhang mit der serie
rechtsextremer droh mails mit dem
absender nsu 2.0 hat die polizei
vorübergehend zwei personen festgenommen
es handelt sich um einen ehemaligen
bayerischen polizeibeamten und seine
frau sie sollen beleidigende
volksverhetzende schreiben etwa an
bundestagsabgeordnete geschickt haben
frage an christian decker aus unserer
justiz redaktion wie schätzen sie diese
festnahme ein
beide befinden sich inzwischen wieder
auf freiem fuß es gibt keinen haftbefehl
weil kein haftgrund vorliegt das wäre
zum beispiel fluchtgefahr
aber es gab eine durchsuchung ihrer
wohnung bei der datenträger
sichergestellt wurden die jetzt von den
ermittlungsbehörden ausgewertet werden
laut staatsanwaltschaft gibt es bislang
keine anhaltspunkte für einen
zusammenhang mit den abfragen auf den
hessischen polizei rechnen
aber der ehemalige polizist ist in der
vergangenheit wegen rechtsmotivierter
straftaten aufgefallen
alles weitere müssen jetzt die
ermittlungen zeigen vielen dank für ihre
informationen christian decker seit zwei
jahren gilt in der eu und damit auch in
deutschland das recht auf vergessen
werden
kurz gesagt wer etwas unangenehmes im
internet über sich liest kann das
löschen lassen
aber nicht in jedem fall hat jetzt der
bundesgerichtshof entschieden
denn auch die gesellschaft hat rechte zb
dass manche dinge eben nicht vergessen
werden
christoph schneider über ein
weitreichendes urteil
er möchte anonym bleiben und auch im
netz nicht mehr gefunden werden der ex
regionalchef eines großen
wohlfahrtsverbandes 2011 wurde über ihn
persönlich berichtet die artikel lassen
sich noch immer finden
er möchte dass diese älteren berichte
über ihn nicht mehr bei google verlinkt
werden und zog gegen den konzern vor
gericht das recht auf vergessen werden
ist in der datenschutz grund verordnung
geregelt danach haben betroffene ein
anspruch auf löschung ihrer
personenbezogenen daten allerdings nicht
immer gerichte müssen abwägen ob im
einzelfall die meinungs- und
informationsfreiheit wichtiger ist als
der datenschutz der bgh weist jetzt
seine klage ab die berichterstattung sei
berechtigt gewesen die verlinkungen in
ordnung dass die artikel inzwischen
bereits neun jahre als sein spiele eine
untergeordnete rolle so der bgh
danach und überwiegt auch unter
berücksichtigung der kommunikations
bedingungen des internet ist jedenfalls
zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt das
fortdauernde öffentliche interesse an
der berichterstattung das
persönlichkeitsrecht des klägers noch
fazit des bgh-urteils die entscheidung
des bgh ist ergebnis eines
abwägungsprozesses den er in jedem
einzelfall neu treffen muss was wiegt
schwerer
die meinungs- und informationsfreiheit
der allgemeinheit oder des datenschutz
interesse des betroffenen
im konkreten fall hat der bgh gesagt
dass die informations interessen der
allgemeinheit vorrang vor dem
datenschutz haben
damit dürfen die artikel vorerst weiter
verbreitet werden
die grundsätzliche frage des rechts auf
vergessen werden im netz sie wird auch
weiterhin eine frage des einzelfalls
bleiben
in münchen haben heute uiguren also
angehörige einer muslimischen
minderheit in china demonstriert und
zwar gegen siemens der konzern
kooperiert nämlich mit einem
chinesischen staatsunternehmen das
überwachungs technologie herstellt und
die hilft nach ansicht von
menschenrechtlern die uiguren in ihrer
heimat zu unterdrücken geschätzt mehr
als eine million menschen sind dort
weggesperrt in umerziehungslager peking
nennt sie berufsbildungszentren aus
münchen jutta sonne wald sie fordern ein
ende der unterdrückung und misshandlung
ihres volkes in der region xinjiang im
nordwesten chinas mitglieder der
chorischen exilgemeinde protestieren vor
der siemens zentrale in münchen gegen
die kooperation des deutschen konzerns
mit dem chinesischen rüstungshersteller
ctc das wird eine provision und durch
diese app werden die uiguren beobachtet
und dieser überwachung führt dazu dass
die uiguren verfolgt werden und in
internierungslager gestellt werden
mit der vom chinesischen staatskonzern
ctc entwickelten app verschafft sich
peking zugriff auf persönliche
informationen der muslimischen
minderheiten ingenieur
das erleichtert die verfolgung und die
sanierung der uiguren siemens bestreitet
etwas mit dieser app zu tun zu haben und
sagt dass der schwerpunkt der
zusammenarbeit zwischen siemens und ctc
rhein im bereich fertigungslösungen
liegt entsprechend lieferte siemens hier
keine produkte die wiederum in möglichen
endprodukten unseres kunden zum einsatz
kommen
ganz gleich ob siemens direkt an der app
beteiligt ist oder nicht
menschenrechtler kritisieren dass der
konzern wie auch andere die in der
region mit chinesischen firmen
kooperieren indirekten
unterdrückungsapparat pekings
unterstützen würde
auf der ebene der politik muss es
sanktionen geben muss es auch ein
lieferketten gesetz geben erst in
deutschland dann in europa auf dessen
grundlage ist keine kooperation mehr mit
unternehmen in china gibt die
menschenrechte verletzen
die usa verhängen bereits gegen solche
firmen sanktionen die bundesregierung
und die deutsche wirtschaft haben
dagegen bisher noch nichts unternommen
dem deutschen wald geht es schlecht laut
statistischem bundesamt wächst die zahl
der geschädigten bäume rasant das
betrifft vor allem nadelhölzer wie
fichten und kiefern
durch die anhaltende trockenheit sind
sie anfällig für schädlinge wie den
borkenkäfer 32 millionen kubikmeter
abgestorbenen bäumen mussten im
vergangenen jahr deswegen gefällt werden
fast sechsmal mehr als 2000 17 der
ausgedörrte wald hat außerdem unter den
stürmen der vergangenen jahre sehr
gelitten
thomas garcia ein paar hundert meter nur
in den hochtaunus dann sieht man die
zerstörung stadt fichten eine lichtung
ein liebloses loch noch vor drei jahren
war hier überall bald alle diese
freiflächen die wir jetzt hier sehen
hinter mir und rechts von mir war alles
vom borkenkäfer befallen der schädling
er fühlt sich wohl in geschwächten
bäumen und tötet sie langsam
bevor der käfer kam kaman sturm und
dürre
wir haben jetzt das dritte jahr in folge
zu wenig niederschläge die bäume mit
die bestände sind geschlecht sie haben
nicht mehr die abwehrkräfte
um diese käfer wenn die in massen
anfliegen abzuwehren und die massen
werden größer denn jedes der tiere liegt
dutzende eier folge noch stärkerer
befall noch mehr wald wird totes holz
insekten stürme trockenheit auch
waldbrände all das gibt es immer mehr
stichwort klimawandel
oft auch gleichzeitig wissenschaftler
sehen zunehmend große flächen die
beschädigt worden sind
es sind alle baumarten betroffen ich
habe ja bewertet dass das eine situation
ist die 600 jahren wahrscheinlich so
nicht gab den wald zu retten im
hochtaunus versucht man es mit schwerem
gerät kaputtes abholzen und mitsamt den
borkenkäfer raus aus dem forst schnell
langfristig sagen experten helfen nur
kluge aufforstung und kampf gegen den
klimawandel
der volt ist krank doch noch kann man
ihm helfen und medienarbeit und zum
alten und neuen italienischen
fußball-meisters turina bis zum 36 mal
geschafft gestern nacht vorzeitiger
titelgewinn durch den sieg in südkorea
genua und wegbereiter war wieder mal
jubel superstar cristiano ronaldo seine
zweite meisterschaft mitzureden
der jubel in turin wirkt routiniert auf
der piazza san carlo und in der kabine
superstar cristiano ronaldo wird wieder
mal zum mann des abends als juventus
kurz vor der pause in führung schießt 31
store in 32 spielen
das 2 0 vom portugiesen vorbereitet und
nach torwartfehler von berner der ski
abgeschlossen ein leichter sieg gegen
sampdoria genua
doch für ronaldo nicht frei von makel
der verschossene strafstoß kurz vor dem
ende
da aber befindet sich der portugiese in
guter gesellschaft weil auch seine
kollegen beste chancen nicht nutzen
können
zwei spieltage vor schluss sieben punkte
vorsprung vor inter mailand juventus
feiert zum neunten mal nacheinander
sebastian hoeneß wird neuer trainer von
1899 hoffenheim
der sohn von dieter und neffe von uli
hoeneß war erfolgreicher drittliga coach
der zweiten mannschaft von bayern
münchen und wird nachfolger vom
entlassenen tsg trainer alfred schröder
er trägt einen großen namen hoeneß
vorname sebastian ein ruhiger besonnener
typ
anders als der papa und der onkel aber
ebenso fußball verrückt sein erstes wort
als kind so sagt der papa war bei heute
mit 38 jahren einer der talentiertesten
nachwuchs trainer zuletzt mit der
zweiten mannschaft des fc bayern meister
in der dritten liga nun sieht es ihnen
von münchen nach hoffenheim ein q für
die tsg
der sportchef alexander rosen sagt wir
stehen schon seit längerer zeit in
kontakt mit sebastian hoeneß da und
seine arbeit imponiert und seine
auffassung von fußball hervorragend zur
philosophie und strategie der tsg passt
hoeneß erhält einen dreijahresvertrag
für sein abenteuer bundesliga schon von
der dritten in die erste liga
toller sprung danke norbert gerne heißt
für die einen eher kühl für die anderen
der juli zeigt sich morgen von ganz
unterschiedlichen seiten mehr dazu hat
gleich katja honnefer so viel von uns
für den moment im heute journal spricht
wenig später claus kleber mit
gesundheitsminister sparen
morgen erwartet sie barbara hahlweg an
dieser stelle danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und noch einen
entspannten abend für sie
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren morgen
zeigt sich der juli von zwei ganz
unterschiedlichen seiten auch heute
schon gab es strahlenden sonnenschein
und schwüle hitze im süden in
norddeutschland dagegen dichtere wolken
die hängen zusammen mit dem tief dana
das brachte heute auch schon etwas regen
mit und auch jetzt in der nacht sind an
der nordsee durchaus regenschauer zu
erwarten
sonst ist es häufig klar und am
oberrhein sinken die temperaturen nicht
unter 20 grad das wird also dort eine
tropische nacht 20 grad ja die hätten
wir vielleicht in nordfriesland morgen
ganz gerne da steigen die werte nämlich
nur auf 19 grad
das ist eine kleine kaltfront die uns
überquert und das merken wir auch daran
dass es im osten morgen sehr warm wird
mit 27 bis 31 grad sehr wetter wirksam
ist die kaltfront allerdings nicht das
fällt mir ein bisschen regen
zwischendurch zeigt sich auch häufig die
sonne
bei einem wind aus westlichen bis
südwestlichen richtungen auch über den
mittelgebirgen tauschen sich morgen die
wolken gefährlich wird es aber erst am
späten nachmittag oder abend wenn ich
hier aus den alpen heraus auch kräftige
gewitter oder regenschauer geben kann
zum teil mit hagel platzregen und
sturmböen
dort wird es morgen nämlich noch am
heißesten mit 30 bis 34 grad und die
aussichten sind einfach nur sommerlich
und heiß schönen abend noch